[Music]
well my name is Liz bobbins I'm teaching
at the llama School of Economics and I'm
actually going to make a move coming
back to the states and I'll take up a
position in University of North Carolina
Chapel Hill on the 1st of January and
last year or last fall I was in the hope
and optimism project in Cornell
University and I was very excited to be
part of this because I'm currently
working on a book project and the I did
the book is called a coping
philosophical guide and so what I would
like to do is actually bring out a lot
of the work that I've been doing in
moral psychology over the last 20 years
and do to put it in a kind of format
that is that is accessible to to the
public to the general public and so the
the main idea of the book project is is
the following well let me start with
there is this kind of well well-worn
prayer of niebuhr and it says that you
know God gave us the courage to change
what we can change and the serenity to
accept what we can change and the wisdom
to know the difference between the two
and now what I think is actually that it
that this is actually a false dichotomy
because there is something in between
accepting the things that we can change
and changing the things that we that we
are able to change having the courage to
change the things that are able to
change and what comes in between
actually is precisely sort of having a
kind of control over over the mind right
and now hoping is exactly the sort of
thing that fits in the space in between
courage and serenity you're not changing
the world and you're not just merely
accepting things I mean you're
developing some kind of attitude of
coping with hardships and that's
precisely I think what is hoping is all
about right I think hoping is actually
just one
of the things that fits in the space
between discourage and serenity another
thing that I've been exploring over the
years is what's often called sour grapes
right now sour grapes is a little bit of
bad rep but if you think about it what
you're really doing or what the Fox is
doing when you can't reach for the
grapes right and it turns his back and
he says oh those grapes are sour right
if you know you could interpret this in
many ways and actually when you think of
this of this fable right it's been
written and rewritten in many ways I
mean it may be the case that the Fox
just says look you know these grapes are
not ripe yet then is that is actually
changing his beliefs in order to deal
with his frustration right but in other
versions he actually says look I really
like grapes so it seems like he's
changing his tastes is changing his
desires that's a different thing and
then the third thing that the Fox might
be doing is he says oh you know grapes
are really for the low life animals in
the woods that is kind of framing the
whole thing right so often I think when
we're trying to deal with hardships in
life we're changing our beliefs we're
changing our desires or we frame things
differently and depending on what you're
doing here these things are either more
or less problematic I think people often
have problems with changing your beliefs
as well right
whereas changing the frame with which
you look at things in order to make
things more acceptable that seems to be
a perfectly all right thing to do right
I mean at one point actually going back
to markers are really as the meditations
see Marcus Aurelius says you know look I
mean Marcus Aurelius have this this
history of spending a lot of time with
soldiers in barracks we're really where
he wanted to be was in Rome and hang out
with it with with people and in high
society right but he says look you know
when you find yourself in a situation
like that you have to come to love the
people with whom you fade this cast and
you have to love them truly so the ideas
really he changes his desire
it changes the way that he frames the
situation in order to make it acceptable
to him and again that's a form of coping
right so you know I'm doing a chapter on
hoping I'm doing a chapter on coping and
then I also try to explore this idea
these ideas in context where where where
things like there's a lot of need for
them like one thing I'm doing currently
is I'm thinking about you know how it is
that people cope with death right and
there is of course a lot of talk of you
know hoping for salvation and an
afterlife and so on but I really want to
think about the idea of what kind of
hopes what kind of secular hopes that we
can have in the face of death right and
so I try to to look at you know various
various components and so to make a kind
of taxonomy of the sort of hopes that
people have in the face of death like
for one thing I think people hope that
their life was worthwhile somehow and I
started actually thinking about this
because a friend of mine you know he
said affair in his late 70s right now he
was a medical doctor and he is currently
you know in his retirement working on a
family tree right and he says to me at a
certain point he says you know the only
thing that I'm proud about in my life
right is this family tree that I made
and I said you know how is this possible
I mean you know look me being a
philosopher right we're kind of envious
of the medical profession in a way right
because it seems so easy for them to
answer the question oh you know do you
do something meaningful in life right
and so what about your patients they
said oh he says my patients he says you
know they're all dead or they're going
to die soon anyway right and I thought
that was really interesting because it
seems like you know the only thing that
he thought would make his life
worthwhile is things that would remain
past is death right and you know to me
actually family trees in genealogy and
so on is a little bit like Trainspotting
so I can't get too excited about it but
I'm definitely envious of
you know I've spent a life in the
medical profession right so then I
started thinking about how is it that we
think about how is it that we hope that
our lives will be worthwhile right and
it seems to me that there is this
difference between thinking about a
worthwhile life in terms of projects
that will extend over you over the
moment of your death versus thinking
about having done great times great
things in life which can be purely
ephemeral right so I'm sort of thinking
about you know a DJ who who'd through
fantastic parties right could say look
nothing of it remains right but at the
same time that party that night that was
a fantastic thing to do
whereas artists in general think about
you know leaving a legacy that goes
beyond their death right the interesting
quote actually by kids in which you know
kids died young of TB and and when he
realizes that he's going to die then he
says you know I haven't been able to
make a mark in life and that bothered
him but he says I've always lived my
life according to an aesthetic principle
right and I think that's quite quite
interesting too because you can think of
you know your life being worthwhile in
terms of ephemeral projects that you've
done in terms of projects that will
extend over your death
but also in terms of living in a
particular mode right living a
particular style of life maybe a life of
self-forgetfulness maybe a life of other
oriented nests or in the case of Keats
living a life in accordance with an
aesthetic principle so that's sort of
the idea of hoping that you've lived a
worthwhile life but I think there's
other hopes that we have to other
secular hopes that we have to you know
in general we just have hopes for the
future right I mean there is this they
saying you know after May the downfall
right but will feel like there's
something wrong with that you should
have hopes for for a better future then
in addition to that I think we also hope
not just to have lived well but also we
hope to die well now that goes back all
the way to Aristotle now Aristotle
actually thought that dying on the
battlefield you know that's what was
really something to strive for and you
know this may seem a little bit outdated
to us but but it's interesting when you
when you know this is justification for
it so he says you know it's a good thing
to die on the battlefield because there
you can show off your prowess and you
can also be doing something Noble
something that would have an effect
after your life right and I think people
like this idea of of dying in a way that
is in accordance with the way that
they've lived and so you know we want to
live our lives I think we want to live
our lives who want to die in a way that
it's kind of reflective of the way that
that we've lived and we want to leave
some kind of legacy as well towards the
towards the future there's a lot of
interesting debate actually going on
recently in in the Netherlands
I mean euthanasia is legalized in the
Netherlands but but the debate right now
is whether if somebody gets a diagnosis
of cancer whether they can have a very
early euthanasia because if they wait
too long none of their organs will be
any good anymore
right and so they ask actually to be
euthanized earlier because they want to
be organ donors and it's the same thing
you want to death to be worthwhile in
some way
you